julie assange has been in captivity for
about or he's been held you know hostage
for 10 years i think about 10 years um
and he's been psychologically tortured
and perhaps physically tortured we don't
know
no one is calling this out no major
media that i've seen has really been
defending julian assange we know all the
reasons for that we've listed them in
this program already
is there any hope for julian assange is
there any way that
he's released or has he been so broken
at this point that you know even if he
was released
it's like they've they've kind of
accomplished what they were looking to
do
um i don't know for sure
i'm the last time i saw julian was in
2018 or 2019 when i went to london and
spent three straight days with him in
the embassy and he
at that time was very lucid very cogent
like in good spirits um
but that was before he was imprisoned he
was still at the embassy although he was
looking very pallid i mean
you know he hasn't been outside in 10
years
right like even prisoners in horrible
american jails get to walk around in the
sun
for like a half an hour an hour a day
julian hasn't he literally hasn't
touched the sun or seen the sun
in 10 years he probably now has in
prison maybe a little bit but when he
was at the embassy he was confined to
a room and a half almost for a full
decade
so he was his health was suffering um
he couldn't exercise he had no son which
is a necessity
you know i the thing that angers me the
most
about the whole situation is you know as
much as the media hates me
when i was doing the snowden reporting
like in 2013 and 2014 and the obama
administration was getting very
threatening i couldn't leave brazil for
like a year
most of the media was on my side and
like defended me why because i was kind
of
i had one foot in their world right like
i was at the guardian
one of the oldest newspapers in the west
and then in 2019 and 2020 when i did
this investigative
reporting in brazil that culminated in
the
indictment by the brazilian government
of me the attempt to criminally
prosecute me as bolsonaro the president
of brazil had threatened to do for
months
most of the american media almost all
american media in fact
manifested in my defense like the new
york times published editorials
you know denouncing it with julian is
completely different because he's never
really had even one
foot in that media clique
and they spent five years flamboyantly
marching around like prancing around as
defenders of press freedom
because trump would like save some
juvenile insult about
jim acosta or post some like mean thing
about chuck todd or wolf blitzer
and they would act like the first
amendment was imperiled and here you
have
an actual grave threat to press freedom
the indictment
that has been unsealed that the biden
administration is now pursuing
if it is if it succeeds it will
criminalize investigative journalism the
relationship that
in fact when the bolsonaro government
tried to criminally prosecute me in 2020
they used that as their model they the
theory that the us government is using
against assange
is the one that the far-right government
in brazil tried to use against me saying
that my relationship between with my
source
had crossed a line from passover seed of
information into an active role in the
conspiracy
to steal the information that i was
reporting which is exactly what they're
using against such
so just out of self-interest you would
think american journalists you pretended
for five years to be so
devoted to defending press freedom when
it came to mean tweets
about like blown dry cnn douchebags
would be protesting and demanding biden
drop the prosecution
but they're not they either don't know
about it they don't care about it or
they're cheering it
because they're infantile and what
really what it really is about
him is just it's pure professional
jealousy
julian assange has broken more big
stories
in the last decade than all of those
corporate media drones
combined right so
he is what they pretend to be and his
existence kind of holds up a mirror
showing what they really are like why
isn't
the cia and the fbi and the nsa devoted
to imprisoning
like wolf blitzer and jim acosta
or like new york times reporters it's
because they're not [ __ ] threats to
anybody
right they're servants so the fact that
they're doing it to julian demonstrates
who the real danger is